heute haben wir projekttag am
augustin-wibbelt-gymnasium wir haben
alle kennen gelernt ali ist ein
flüchtling aus dem irak er versucht im
moment deutsch zu lernen
dabei wollen ihm helfen indem die
gegenstände in der schule beschreiben
wir hoffen dass es auch für euch
nützlich was ist das das ist eine tafel
das ist die tafel was macht man mit
einer tafel auf der tafel schreiben wir
mit der kreide
was ist das das ist ein stück kreide
das ist die kreide was ist das das ist
ein schwamm
das ist der schwarm was macht man mit
dem schwamm mit dem schwamm wische ich
die tafel ab und was ist das
das ist ein tisch das ist der tisch ich
sitze am tisch ist sitze an dem tisch
was ist das das ist ein stuhl dass der
stuhl
was machst du mit dem stuhl ich sitze
auf dem stuhl
und was ist das das ist ein mülleimer
das ist der mülleimer wozu brauchst du
den mülleimer ich schmeiße müll in den
mülleimer was ist das das ist ein plakat
das ist das plakat und was ist das das
ist eine tür dass es die tür
ich öffne die tür ich schließe die tür
und was ist das das ist ein
klassenzimmer das ist das klassenzimmer
wir sitzen im klassenzimmer
was ist das das ist ein lehrer pult das
ist das lehrerpult hier sitzt der lehrer
was ist das das ist ein waschbecken dass
es das waschbecken
hier stehe ich mir die hände was ist das
das ist ein wörterbuch dass es das
wörterbuch und was ist das das ist ein
fehler dass der füller was machst du mit
dem füller mit dem füller schreibe ich
was ist das das war eine klingel
das war die klingel was ist das das ist
ein tintenkiller das ist der
tintenkiller was machst du mit dem
tintenkiller ich korrigiere meine fehler
was ist das das ist ein radiergummi
das ist das radiergummi und was ist das
das ist ein geodreieck das ist das
geodreieck und was ist das dass es ein
taschenrechner dass es der
taschenrechner was machst du mit dem
taschenrechner mit dem taschenrechner
löse ich mathe aufgaben
was ist das das ist ein etui dass es das
etui was hast du in deinem etui indem es
sind meine stifter und was ist das das
ist ein college block das ist der
college block was machst du mit dem
college block
ich reiße ein blatt aus dem college
block und was ist das das ist ein
rucksack dass es der rucksack was machst
du
ich nehme meinen rucksack und gehe nach
hause